okay
the los angeles rams have made no secret
of their
ambivalence at best toward franchise
quarterback jared goff it's therefore no
surprise that it's now being reported
that the rams will have an open
quarterback competition because of
course they will and one of the reasons
jared goff will be part of the
competition they can't
get rid of him right they've been saying
that all month they can't they own 43
million guaranteed over the next two
years the cap hit for cutting him would
would be all of that plus another 22
million trading him as 22 million oh and
no one's trading for jared goff so it's
jared goff and whoever else they bring
in they've added duck hodges recently
and frankly the way jared goff's been
playing lately beard golf doc hodges i
don't know
so chris uh hey it's amazing how quickly
this has fallen apart two years two
years is not two years like that right
super bowl quarterback
brandon cooks open in the end zone yeah
was that the moment but they still paid
him after that though that i know he's
astounding to me yeah they paid him all
that money yeah negotiations two seasons
later right they're done with him right
it is amazing uh it's amazing too i
think just from the standpoint of where
they never really wavered the first few
years of even anything negative towards
jared goff he could have a bad game and
sean mcveigh would still sit there with
a straight face and tell you it was
pretty good and we're all behind jared
and all those things right he never
wavered but something
at the end of this year
finally was like enough is enough we
gotta we can't just roll out the red
carpet because we've given him a
contract and he's our quarterback we
can't just keep letting them have a free
pass of oh you play average and it's
okay and we'll we'll talk kindly to the
media and everybody else about you um
they've let it be known you're right
they have not like
they they haven't come out and said it
but
they haven't minced words to let you
know that they're not happy and that
there's an issue there and now yeah we
hear a report finally to finally confirm
that hey it's going to be a competition
what i want to know mike is is this
going to be him versus wolford or is it
going to be something where
they look
you know to bring in a guy too
like you know i don't know just just for
instance a jacoby bersette or just some
guy or out there who we know is you know
a starter borderline backup starter type
of guy right that might be out there on
the market this year i'm not saying
definitively him i'm just saying that
type of scenario will they bring
somebody in like that or are they just
going to let these two go at it
well i'm going to say this next thing
knowing full well there's a chance we
maybe interview him next week although
it probably won't be me i could help
broken the deal for kirk cousins to la
if sean mcvay is interested in a reunion
with the former washington quarterback
and i know that mcveigh has raved
privately about kirk cousins yeah so
it's the cap you combine the cap charge
for cousins and the money you're going
to have to eat whether he's on the
roster or not for golf and it just isn't
going to happen and i'd like to think
the vikings wouldn't do a cousins for
golf trade straight up here's here's my
explanation
for why mcvay was so
blindly over the top supportive and
loyal and a head coach taught me this
lesson a few years ago
you've got
two types of guys who play quarterback
the natural leaders and the guys who
need help yeah the natural leaders they
just take over the team the guys who
aren't like goff and and a lot of
quarterbacks aren't natural leaders yeah
it's incumbent on the team
and the coach
to be the one who is the consummate and
non-stop unconditional cheerleader so
everyone in the organization knows he's
the guy so what's happened
over the course of the last two seasons
either the locker room is starting to
question the sanity of sean mcvay
or
or
jared goff isn't working hard enough
that they think jared goff isn't doing
what he needs to do that he's behind the
scenes not
in his playbook enough not
showing up early enough not staying late
enough because you can excuse poor
performance if there's effort there but
if there's poor performance and you see
signs of lack of effort that's when i
think a coach is going to turn on a guy
so i i suspect something like that has
happened
and and they've got no interest in
saying that if they hold out hope for
trading him but it could be once he got
that second contract you know the first
contract wasn't true generational
life-changing money the second one is
and maybe now that he's gotten that
maybe he's maybe he's got a little
complacent and maybe they're just done
with trying to get him to to take it as
seriously as they need him to take i i
don't doubt any of that i i don't know
you know complacency comfort
when the coach never brings anybody in
to compete with you
you know and you got
a coach who's always saying positive
things about you
and and you can do no wrong even when
you maybe do do wrong
i mean i think natural human emotions
are you know we talk about you know you
got to have a little fire under your
butt that's part of being a head coach
you know it's one thing with john gruden
hey i'll you say what you want when he
brought in other quarterbacks and things
like that yeah he was pushing me but
then there was the other quarterback too
that well you brought him in he seems
like he kind of likes him i better get
working i better doing those things he
never let me feel comfortable that way
and i feel like they let jared goff feel
comfortable and made him feel like
you're almost like patrick mahomes like
that's how i felt like they've treated
him almost until just this past year and
then the other thing mike that i think
and you kind of brought it up to where
you got to be careful of giving the guy
a free pass all the time
because you know the in the locker room
right this kind of goes back to like
oddly enough one of jalen ramsey's old
teammates and the blake bortles thing or
the jacksonville jaguars you know if
you're gonna let one guy off the hook
all the time and yet the other 52 are
going to be accountable to everything
they do and every mistake and all that
but then this one guy gets off the hook
you'll lose the locker room where
they're just going to be like what i
don't understand he never coaches him
he's the reason we lost and there's
nothing negative said we don't even say
anything in the coaches you know in the
team meeting nothing's ever even
addressed with it and i think that's
where it's got to be you know you got to
be a little careful as an organization
of that as well
and blake bortles would go on to back up
jared goff for a year before it became
john walford the guy that it sure seemed
like sean mcvay wanted yeah to be the
starter in the divisional round game
against the packers a week after wolford
started and goff was a little salty
because he's saying hey my thumb's fine
i can play
this may be the start of the process of
getting him
to wake up bring in definition get him
to wake up you know you're stuck with
him they know they're stuck with him but
they're sending out these messages that
are very very ominous and negative and
they're trying to coach goff publicly in
a way that will coax better performance
out of and you mentioned my homes he out
dueled mahomes in that game that was
supposed to be in mexico city that
monday night game for the ages from
2018. that was not that long ago in the
grand scheme of things but he had todd
gurley at the time and it was just a
different vibe it was a different sense
it was a different offense and golf was
a different quarterback then yeah plain
and simple since he's gotten paid he's
become a different guy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports